the news spreads like wildfire through
the streets and in the barrios of
Caracas people start running with
buckets and virtually anything they can
find to carry water others run in the
opposite direction trying to get home to
tell the family to come this is
desperate stuff Venezuela's capital has
no power to pump water so they're
exposing leaking pipes to gather what
they can sometimes it's just a trickle
they wait their turn however long it
takes
Jose Perez has taken five hours to
gather 20 litres of water
he has no idea if it's clean enough to
drink no consequence apparently manana
some have resorted to gathering water
for noir a river that runs through the
center of the city and this really is
polluted there are many reports of
people particularly children getting ill
from contaminated water and food the
crisis caused by the power out is far
from being dealt with
above us on a bridge and man sees us
filming and he shouts down maduro is an
assassin he says the people need to
march on the presidential Paris and get
rid of him
many of these people would doubtless
agree the opposition call them out on
the streets to protest against the
government of Nicolas Maduro and the
chaos caused by the nationwide blackmail
they took over streets in parts of the
city Karl supporting the cause the
United States promising new sanctions
against Venezuela which could bring
about even more shortages and disruption
here it's clear that the situation in
the country will continue to deteriorate
the crisis in Venezuela is getting worse
still Ramsey Sky News correct